Charles Barkley hall-of-famer inside the
NBA on TNT joining us and whoa what do
you got in the background there is that
your man cave this is my man cave my gym
and my bar so I got a bunch of stuff on
in my bar and my workout room from a
dream team this is actually I got this
all assigned by the original dream team
from 92 it's one of my most prized
possessions
Isaiah Thomas's autograph is not on that
right it is not okay
I asked Reggie Miller can we get this
out of the way I asked Reggie Miller on
Monday I said do you think Michaels said
to the commissioner I'll do the dream
team but I say it doesn't get to play I
don't have any idea about that to be
honest with you Dan but you know I've
told Isaiah who I really like a lot that
was never presented to me in a like hey
do you want Isiah on the team so I have
heard the rumors I don't know what's
true and was not true so I just don't
know to answer your question but that
was never presented to me was it true
that Isiah froze out Michael or tried to
in the all-star game but I'm asking you
oh okay forty years it's crazy you think
that's crazy that he would have tried to
freeze out Michael in the all-star game
yeah I don't think you could get every
guy mean you got to get all the guys to
agree to that so I don't believe that at
all is that Shaq's shoe over your
shoulder this is the second dream team
this is Circle dream team to stop I got
on the wall they stuff on the original
dream team under this flag I got here
people might still did it won't steal
this stuff I got the original Dream Team
stuff other this flag I got that stuff
here
got a magic Johnson practice jury today
our stove
I got a Michael Jordan practice jersey
that I stole but but the rest up is here
did you sit down for the Jordan
documentary idea and what was the top
what were the topics that they broached
with you oh I actually don't remember
Dan it was done like pretty much a year
ago so I really don't remember what we
talked about did you have any beef with
Michael never me and Michael always been
COO he was always like a brother to me
and he treated me great obviously that's
changed now but the documentary has been
I don't think there's anything shocking
in there to be honest with you well I
think we looked at Jerry Krause was the
villain and then it wasn't no no he was
portrayed as the villain because you
know at the end because he took it apart
he didn't take that apart anybody think
that's a fool that thing was all
orchestrated by Jerry Reinsdorf the
notion that that little man broke up the
bull is asinine and absurd hey listen
Jack if you go back and look at it and
use common sense just use plain common
sense
Jim Reinsdorf broke up the Bulls cuz he
didn't want to pay anybody you think
about this he let her harvest grand robe
because he became a free agent didn't
want to pay him they probably won't talk
about that in the dr. Murray that's why
he left and went to Orlando he only paid
Michael the last two years yeah when he
had Michael at a bargain he was happy so
he didn't want to pay Michael he paid
him those last two years and he had
Scotty under a great deal that's the
reason he broke up the bull strictly
because of money but to try to make
Jerry cross to be the bad guy I thought
that was very decent disingenuous
I agree after I watched that documentary
those first two episodes I came in on
Monday and I said why is it that Jerry
Reinsdorf the owner has no blood on his
hands in this well because he's that's
the way he is he's the silent assassin
he's my man from that movie to
professional you come in and kill you
know
and Jerry Krause isn't around to defend
himself that that was what you know he
he helped build that team and then it
felt like he was Yoko Ono blaming him
for the breakup of the Beatles it
doesn't even matter if he was around
number one rest in peace but the notion
that Jerry Krause broke up the Bulls
dare come on man if Jan arrives dog
won't the Bulls to stay together they
would have stayed together I mean just
let somebody take Jerry Krause Oliver
the son became a hand and broke up the
bull I think that it's just stupid and
you not pay your bill okay I think it's
your bill then I have a spittin money on
anything in like two months what are you
doing at home like how do you pass the
time what a good thing I'm back in
Arizona so I started a regiment while I
work out twice a day nice I played golf
three wait three days a week I can only
drink on Friday and Saturday so it's
been I've been trying to do that's all I
could do you know I love to drink but I
know I could not drink every day so I
quit drinking except on Friday and
Saturday I got a big golf match today
with a bunch of the coyote hockey
players we play about three days a week
we got like a round a cup or mats so
today's a big day in the Berkeley golf
world talking to Charles Barkley the
Hall of Famer joining us Dan Patrick
show the Isiah Thomas looks like an
apology tour here about not shaking
hands with the Bulls my reaction with
that chuck was own it you're the Bulls
you were the bad boys who cares if you
didn't shake Mike's hand I'm like I just
didn't I like laimbeer's approach he's
like yeah I don't we didn't know there
were whiners I don't want to shake their
hands first of all they were wrong they
should have shook their hands so they
should have did you know Athena was
amazing if you go back when I saw that
even after they had beat the hell out of
Michael he
[ __ ] their hands yep I mean I'm not sure
if guy had beat me to a pulp three years
in a row I'd shake your hand but Michael
went up to their hands went up to them
and shook their hands and said
congratulations
listen pitches were wrong I think we've
all did things in our life that we would
like to go back the pistols were wrong
and Menaul they've led to this Dean get
out of hand if they just have a said and
I love Isaiah I love working with him I
lack of a lot he probably gets the least
amount of respect out of all the great
players in NBA history but all they had
to do to put out this breast fire is hey
we we were wrong we should have shook
their hands you can't let this thing
simmer and let the media and let all
these idiots on something that not you
Dan you know who I'm talking about you
can't let these idiots on other networks
when I say it is you know I mean it's
got Baylor's you can't let idiots and
fools like that just throw gasoline on a
fire as there who I love should have
just said hey we were wrong and this
thing would have been over yeah my point
was you're known as the bad boys okay
you didn't shake Mike's hand so what
Mike was the other Mike super high Mike
was the bigger man with that chalk you
know what you can't just say people
hands when you win that was a bad thing
about I know they're wrong Chuck I know
they're wrong but you're the bad boys
the way you played was wrong they beat
home yes it was yes it was they beat up
my look at the video of what they did to
Jordan that was a real basketball that
was the rules though well that was it
was a shame that David Stern allowed the
Knicks and the Pistons to play that kind
of basketball Miami yeah Miami Heat did
too
you're right yeah they had a heck of a
team they have a bunch of good players I
mean obviously Joe Dumars or Isaiah
great great players and Dennis was a
hell of a player but they still had been
in Johnson Laimbeer was a good little
player I mean Sally was a good
James Edwards I mean they had a good
team had a great team they had a great
debt and underrated I said that we just
didn't like that style but that team was
a great team he had a Hall of Fame coach
you had Hall of Famers with Rodman was
unbelievable back then that that version
of Denis was incredible
yes agreed
you didn't have any run well you had run
in with Laimbeer you you were gonna
fight him or did you throw all the two
guys on that team could fight Isiah and
Joe Dumars like Rodman can fight Sally
can fight Mahorn can fight Laimbeer can
fight I mean not very Johnson Vinnie
Johnson and James Edwards - they fight
but the main four guys I just mentioned
these none of them could fight a lick
but they were Laimbeer was always
starting he was an instigator there he
was go back and look at all the
highlights he was always getting punched
in the head started the fight he didn't
come the fight he's slim and he's sexy
joining us from his man cave Charles
Barkley you'd look good I'm happy I am
NOT going to complain because man I just
want to shout out to all the first
responders out there all the nurses and
all the doctors who are no normal unless
you're a cop or a farmer you don't have
to risk your life every day but I just
feel I just feel sad on so many fronts I
mean like I say the first responders but
all these people who in the restaurant
business are gonna lose their job who
have lost their job and are going to
lose their jobs because even when this
pandemic is over a lot of these
restaurants are
number one people are not gonna have
money to go there and eat but also
people gonna be afraid gonna be afraid
to congregate so this thing is going to
be catastrophic
for a lot of people in the restaurant
industry so my thoughts are with them so
I'm not gonna complain at all I mean yes
I'm bored I'm not even worried about the
NBA coming back I'm not worried about
Colorado NHL coming back I'm not worried
about football I'm just worried about
the big picture cuz man the most
important thing how are we gonna do this
and keep anybody safe I mean III I don't
know how you can do it and keep people
safe yeah I just don't see fans coming
back being able to come back until OH
oh damn right that's that's going out
the window
that's not even we should even be
discussing that there's no fans coming
to sporting events if we store a plan
again that ain't guy that's got zero
chance of happening my concern is how
are we gonna get and I mean obviously
the three most important sports right
now but football got some time hockey
which I love the Stanley Cup Playoffs
the NBA playoffs and Major League
Baseball how are we gonna keep the
players safe I mean and people who got
to be around yeah let me tell you
something I was talking to my lawyer he
says if you guys get one of these people
sick and they die or one of these
players die legally we're gonna be up a
creek yeah I'll leave you with this the
report came out that Michael Jordan
decided to do this documentary had all
this footage and they said that they
won't release an NBA entertainment will
not release it until Michael says that
they can release and he said no for
decades then on the day LeBron wins the
championship mmm you know Clini he's in
Cleveland and Michael says he tells the
producer okay let's do this
do you think that's just a coincidence
or maybe it's Mike's way of saying let
me remind simpie
people and inform a new generation of
just how damn good I was well I don't
know the answer to that question but
there's a couple things about this
documentary number one
when just looking at Michael talking the
Royal am Tom but I'm a nobody that's
gonna work harder than me and nobody
ever has and two and then when he wanted
to come back to play with the broken
foot and Jerry says no you're gonna risk
your career he just wanted to play and I
wish the number one thing that these
young players today get out of this
documentary you can have all the
followers you want you can make all the
money you want the most important thing
it's being the best player that's what I
hope these young guys get out of this
but I managed to finish up with this
what he went through against the Bulls
that's what makes me that's what to me
makes him the greatest player ever no
disrespect to coal because coal poster
closes I've seen - - Michael no
disrespect to LeBron who's an amazing
man number one an amazing player but to
get beat down like that and keep coming
back that was that reminded me like why
I think this dude is the greatest
basketball player ever I mean because
the way they play the NBA today then and
I'm not too old get off my long guy and
you said it earlier what they did to
that dude three years in a row for him
to keep coming back look that that's
what make him the goat okay
back to my question do you think Michael
this was a calculated move on the day
LeBron wins the championship he decides
to do it let allow them to do a
documentary on the last year of the
Bulls ask you I know you don't know
everything but you know Michael is the
most competitive guy you've ever been
around and that to me it was Michaels
saying yeah you know LeBrons want
another title here maybe you know let me
just put this out there and just let
people just remind them of how great I
was
well let me tell you something if
his goal we are reminded as a person who
lived the Jordan era listen man I say
I'm not trying to be the old guy you
watching these highlights
bring back some serious some serious
memories how great this guy was I mean
is it's incredible to relive it is
incredible to relive it I mean I know
his old have a long time ago you know
what Reggie Miller said to me Chuck
he said if he I said what would happen
if he ran into Jordan and he goes I
might want to punch him
I might hug him or punch him Reggie
still has he really had a hard time like
it was sports drama after watching those
first two episodes he was like still mad
at Jordan like for their relationship
their rivalry well you know I saw some
guys tried to make a big deal out of
Michael playing golf with Danny Ainge
one day yeah and I see these young guys
don't get it we're not mad about them
playing golf together we're mad about
them all teaming up together that ain't
the same that ain't the same yeah we've
all played golf at different times but
we never said hey man let's get me there
and dominate the lead that's what the
different aspect of being friends with
guys and we never all got together said
let's dominate the league that's good
I'm glad you're healthy and you know
good morn-ting I miss you man you guys
be safe you know keep keep your distance
and bless all y'all man one of these
days we're doing the show from the
Berkeley Estates hey you know I changed
the name I make it a compound now
because I got a yeah I got a basketball
a tennis court now in the backyard and
you don't use either one of those well I
got a putting green - and you don't use
that either
oh I'll practice my pudding every day
now damn
good you welcome at the compound anytime
I like that and do you have bunk beds so
when I bring out the dance that dance
house oh yeah I like it Thank You bud
thanks for having me god that's Charles
Barkley